Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Silvina Katz
Observa esta imagen.
¿Qué será esto?
¿Un monstruo aterrador?
¿Dos osos amigables?
¿U otra cosa totalmente diferente?
Durante casi un siglo,
se emplearon diez láminas
con manchas de tinta como estas
para realizar pruebas
de la personalidad casi místicas.
Por mucho tiempo, fueron confidenciales
entre el psicólogo y sus pacientes
y se sostenía que las enigmáticas imágenes
podían evidenciar el funcionamiento
de la mente humana.
Pero ¿qué pueden indicarnos
realmente estas manchas
y cómo funciona esta prueba?
Inventada a principios del siglo XX por
el psiquiatra suizo, Hermann Rorschach,
la prueba de Rorschach no se centra tanto
en las cosas específicas que vemos,
sino en nuestro enfoque
general de percepción.
Al ser un artista aficionado,
a Hermann le fascinaba cómo la percepción
visual varía según la persona.
Mantuvo este interés durante
su formación como médico,
donde aprendió que todos nuestros
sentidos están estrechamente conectados.
Estudió cómo los procesos de percepción no
solamente registran entradas sensoriales,
sino que las transforman.
Y cuando empezó a trabajar
en un hospital psiquiátrico
al este de Suiza,
comenzó a diseñar
un conjunto de imágenes crípticas
para comprender mejor
este proceso enigmático.
Con ayuda de sus láminas
con manchas de tinta,
Rorschach comenzó a hacer a cientos de
personas sanas y pacientes psiquiátricos
la misma pregunta:
¿Qué será esto?
Sin embargo,
lo más importante para Rorschach no
era lo que los sujetos de la prueba veían,
sino cómo abordaban la tarea,
en qué partes de la imagen
se focalizaban, cuáles ignoraban,
si veían la imagen en movimiento,
si el color de algunas manchas
los ayudaban a dar mejores respuestas,
o si el color los distraía y abrumaba.
Desarrolló un sistema para codificar
las interpretaciones de los sujetos,
y redujo el amplio abanico de respuestas
a una cantidad manejable.
De esta forma, contaba
con medidas empíricas
para cuantificar a todos
los sujetos de la prueba:
los creativos e imaginativos,
los detallistas, los que veían
el cuadro completo,
y participantes flexibles
capaces de adaptar su enfoque.
Algunas personas se bloqueaban
y ofrecían las mismas respuestas
ante distintas láminas.
Otros hacían descripciones
fascinantes y poco comunes.
Las respuestas eran
tan variadas como las láminas,
que planteaban distintos tipos
de problemas de percepción,
algunos más sencillos
de interpretar que otros.
Pero el análisis del enfoque
general de los sujetos
proporcionó un entendimiento
real de su personalidad.
A medida que Rorschach realizaba
la prueba a más y más personas,
los patrones comenzaron a acumularse.
Los sujetos sanos
con el mismo tipo de personalidad
con frecuencia tenían enfoques similares.
Los pacientes que padecían
del mismo trastorno mental
también daban respuestas similares.
La prueba se convirtió en una
herramienta de diagnóstico fiable.
Podía incluso diagnosticar
ciertos trastornos
que eran difíciles de identificar
mediante los métodos disponibles.
En 1921
Rorschach publicó su sistema
de codificación y diez láminas
que brindaban, según su opinión, la imagen
más completa de la percepción humana.
En las décadas que siguieron,
la prueba se hizo extremadamente popular
en países de todo el mundo.
Hacia la década de 1960,
ya se había administrado de forma oficial
millones de veces tan solo en EE. UU.
Desafortunadamente, tras menos
de un año de haber publicado la prueba,
Hermann Rorschach falleció repentinamente.
Sin su artífice que la controlara,
la prueba ideada a partir de numerosos
datos recolectados metódicamente
comenzó a usarse de formas
especulativas de todo tipo.
Algunos investigadores sometían
a criminales nazis a esta prueba
con la esperanza de llegar
a las raíces psicológicas del genocidio.
Algunos antropólogos
mostraban las imágenes
a miembros de comunidades remotas
como una prueba de personalidad universal.
Los empleadores demostraban
prejuicios al contratar,
pues reducían la prueba
a tablas de decodificación.
A medida que la prueba abandonó la clínica
y se insertó en la cultura popular,
su reputación entre profesionales
médicos se vino abajo,
y ya no se incluían las láminas
en ámbitos clínicos.
En la actualidad, la prueba
sigue siendo controvertida,
y muchas personas dan por sentado
que ha sido refutada.
Pero en 2013 una revisión masiva de toda
la investigación existente de Rorschach
demostró que, administrada correctamente,
la prueba conduce a resultados válidos
que pueden ayudar en el diagnóstico
de enfermedades mentales
o a completar el perfil
psicológico de un paciente.
Claramente no es por sí sola
una puerta a la mente humana,
ninguna prueba lo es,
pero su enfoque visual y el no imponer
una única respuesta correcta
sigue ayudando a los psicólogos
a crear una imagen más detallada
de cómo las personas ven el mundo.
Y esto nos trae un paso más cerca
de comprender los patrones
de nuestra percepción.